we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is our
old friend
troy york who was very triggered by the
discussion of donald trump's IQ and he
wants dr fowey arrested hey dat pac-man
is watching your video when you had to
call her the female caller who fast
president Trump saying he has a low IQ
and asking you when he thought his IQ
was this is Troy your cane I think that
woman's IQ was sixty six eleven years is
seventy five and I think you are in this
have deep pockets for the deep state and
Communist China type Trump has done a
great job he needs to overrule these
also Tyrion leaders in the blue states
who tried to wreck our economy for
political power and because I hate
Trump's person and I think that
President Trump will over roll please
stay at home order selves a disaster for
our economy we're having dr. Anthony
Fauci should be arrested for treason
faulty and basically this has been a
concentrated campaign I believe from the
far left to discredit and once again
attack this country capitalism right so
there so that when when we talk about
confident weaponized arrogance and
ignorance that's what we're talking
about arrest foul Chi this is all a
left-wing plot you've got a 75 IQ that's
what we're talking about and that's
someone who I mean it's really a case
study no matter what that's someone
who's voting for Trump in November no
matter how many deaths happen as a
result of Trump's action so that's what
we're fighting against and that's why I
get out the vote rather than argue with
people is the strategy that we must
employ let me remind you Thursday April
9 membership explosion one-day
membership special were down like 75
members already in April we lost 389 in
March because of the virus we are
putting together a one-day huge
membership special email will go out on
Thursday April 9th to be notified all
you need to do is get on our newsletter
okay go to david pakman.com on the
website you type in your email address
you're on the
letter Thursday 2 p.m. Eastern 11:00
a.m. Pacific you will get that beautiful
beautiful email and of course membership
includes the bonus show coming up right
after this